so
we got here on tuesday and then we just
kind of walked around aimlessly
trying to find a parking spot and went
to comedy shows
we saw the chris gethard show
i haven't done anything other than
attempt to go see other comedy shows
i have not watched any music
i had a really hefty game of ping pong
with peter
and i'm not sure who won because we
stopped keeping score
i think i i was really focusing on my
serve
but peter was like he was like in it for
the long game like he was going to get
me at the end of each set
so he had a better strategy i think
overall wednesday
we played at uh this place called holy
mountain we did like a label showcase
with other bands that are on our label
like waxahachie and california x
that was really cool and then right
after that we took all of our stuff
and we got to cut through the alleyway
behind the two venues so it was actually
like
200 feet maximum that we just carried
all of our
things all the way over to the other
venue
it was super easy and i had no idea it
was going to be that easy but then we
played at barbarella
at 12 30 all our friends and paper moons
and then our friends in austin
and uh our friends from the chris
gethard show were there
and so it was just like really positive
and i could hear my vocals
that was nice
we are on my uncle's boat called
margaritaville unlike travis
we like to stay here every time we're in
texas
in austin because it's a really nice
wonderful place to be
outside of the craziness and when we get
to hang out with family
it's nice
my uncle has a limo and he drove us out
to
enchanted rock and it's basically this
giant
dome of pink granite that's just kind of
bulging out of the earth
we climbed it and it was really hard and
alex peter and dave had a pretty easy
time of it so that's annoying
but i had a hard time it took like two
hours to get out there
and uh it was it was great and we just
climbed to the top
we ran down we drove back and then got
out of the car
and went to a show last time we were
just like oh
we're just going to play everything and
it's going to be crazy and we had no
idea what was going on and we were
overwhelmed
this time was a little less crazy on the
playing shows front a little more crazy
on the press front
we met with our radio person today
and then yesterday we met with a label
in the uk that
we might work with our new record's out
april 23rd
it's called wheel the new tour is in
sport of the record
and we haven't done a headline tour in a
really long time so um
we're just really excited to get out on
the road
to the other side
so
is
all right thanks so
the clapping much snapping instead of
the clock